well as tensions continue to rise there
fighting has also been continuing along
the Israel Lebanon border hostilities
there resumed after the Gaza ceasefire
ended on Friday morning let's speak to
our correspondent Zena H she's in
southern Lebanon for us Zena can you
talk us through these latest attacks you
were reporting on exchanges across that
border yesterday
too throughout Saturday heavy exchange
of fire along the Lebanon Israel border
the Lebanese Army group Hezbollah joined
the battle on behalf of Hamas in the
sense that its stated goal is to help
relieve the pressure on Gaza it believes
that it is bogging down a number of
divisions of the Israeli Army on the nor
northern northern front so Hezbollah
launching a series of attacks on Israeli
military positions along the border
Israel launching a series of air strikes
uh artillery strikes targeting um the
outskirts of Border Villages really
along that 120 km stretch of territory
the Israeli Army also using white
phosphorus artillery shells they use
this as a military tactic to burn bushes
to burn forests uh where Hezbollah is
able to launch attacks from so it is
really an ongoing confrontation uh the
first few weeks it was sporadic exchange
of fire a few weeks later it became more
intense now has B's engagement is very
much limited the question is when will
that change um Israel's too it's its
response also confined to areas along
the border now Hezbollah has said that
things could change depending on what
happens in Gaza what happens in Lebanon
will hasbalah join the fight with his
full-blown military capabilities if it
feels that its Ally Hamas can no longer
sustain attacks now so this is still you
know a very much active war zone you see
Israeli planes overhead flying medium to
high Al multitude Israeli drones
constantly in the sky tens of thousands
of people forced to leave their homes
even during the Gaza ceasefire when it
was quiet along the border uh people did
not have enough time to harvest their
crops uh so this is taking a toll really
on the tens of thousands of people who
live along the border so we are
expecting these skirmishes these heavy
exchanges of fire to continue as long as
the the attacks on Gaza continue this is
at least what the Lebanese armed group
has Says Z there with that report for us
from the ground in southern Lebanon
thank you Zena well joining me now on
set is Sami HZ he's an associate
professor of anthropology at
Northwestern University here in katar
sami's written extensively about the
Arab world and he's also the author of
The forthcoming book my brother my land
a story from Palestine Samy you've also
written a book on violence in Lebanon so
so let me start there we were hearing
there from Zena about how hezbollah's
engagement has been limited so far how
is hea making their calculations here I
mean I think the the calculations we
we're walking on a very sort of thin
line uh and this could explode in any
moment but look I I think the the
problem here is that if we had a
self-respecting International Community
or self-respecting
uh Arab countries on the border like
Jordan or Egypt or you wouldn't need
hasah to be taking on this essentially
right to protect right I mean RZA is
under attack and nobody is trying to to
protect so you have this armed group
that's uh that's doing it so you could
resolve this by actually having a a sort
of more International response to to
prevent these escalations what do you
make then of what Regional powers and
and Arab states have been doing so far
in terms of their engagement we saw a
meeting between a number of Arab leaders
and KLA Harris the US Vice President
yesterday after which she seemed to
change her tone is there some behind the
scenes diplomacy here that's making any
kind of impact the thing is it's talk
and talk and talk but then they need to
actually uh act and I think you know
it's it's really important that they
send a signal to the world that we're
ready to act that there needs to be
International intervention I think that
you know calling for ceasefire you know
on one hand yes the the way that macron
is talking the way that CA har is
talking is obviously a move movement
from the beginning of this war but you
know it's not enough and if there isn't
a sort of push I think you know if Riyad
Mansour speaks so well at the at the UN
General Assembly but if he were to call
call on the World to actually intervene
and make you know actually put some uh
teeth to what you're talking about let
me ask you what you mean there by
International intervention you're
talking about boots on the ground
obviously Arab states have been very
clear they don't want to have Arab boots
on the ground and and they've also said
that they have red lines that we've
heard a lot about not redrawing the map
of Gaza from comma Harrison in the last
day which appears to now be a new red
line for the us but when you say
International intervention you're
suggesting that that we we would yes yes
I mean you know they did this in I I
said this earlier this morning if they
did this in Libya after one speech by
KFI you know obviously this isn't going
to happen what I'm what I'm saying isn't
going to happen but we need to put it on
the table let Israel understand that its
actions have repercussions and it's not
just talk and then it's not just MRA
coming and they sit and they shake hands
and they talk about the two-state
solution nobody has any idea how this
two-state solution would actually pan
out Israel has destroyed it it's become
a one state apartheid so you know we can
talk about two-state solution but in
effect we're going they want to take us
back to the slow genocide that's been
happening in the West Bank as well it
feels like we're a long long way away
from any kind of intervention that
you're describing I mean at this stage
we're hearing the US now ramp up
rhetoric around the protection of
civilians I mean we're starting there at
the moment is that is that likely to
make any kind of a difference we've
obviously heard these calls from the US
to Israel throughout this conflict is is
there a change on the horizon the world
the war will end but the issue is that
do we is it going to end after another
10 or 20 you know so we're at 30 40,000
deaths I mean this has surpassed in the
last year of Russia's attack and
invasion of Ukraine you haven't had
nearly as many children dying in one
year right I think the ratio is five
times more in one month so you know
eventually yeah they'll move the dial to
have a ceasefire but what will it take
and I think you know and and then we are
at October 7 again or October 6 and I
think we need really Creative Solutions
to move us forward you mentioned the
occupied West Bank obviously what we're
talking about in terms of the tensions
here you alluded to that there well
preceded this war but do you think that
the settler violence that we've been
seeing particularly in the occupied West
Bank has that now taken on a new
dimension it certainly feels like it has
it I I don't know if it's taken a a new
dimension I think it's it was escalating
before October 7 and we had over 20000
deaths in this last year I mean the the
settlers have grown since Oso from
150,00 settlers to now 750,000 settlers
and they've become extremely racist and
fascist and armed and we talk about the
horrific uh Hamas attacks but we never
talk about the horrific settler attacks
we talk about them as settler attacks we
never add all these you know 10
adjectives to these settler attacks to
describe them when we saw what happened
yesterday these they they attack I mean
and they've been attacking and burning
cars and burning shops for the last two
years uh it's uh it's disheartening and
and it is all you need to do is show
your viewers a map of a shrinking West
Bank right and that shrinking West Bank
is a form of slow
genocide Sami homz an associate
professor of anthropology at
Northwestern University thank you for
joining me here in the studio